[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm fish behind and today we're
talking about live practices in Aikido
so today we're gonna do kind of a semi
live practice so I would say this is
alive practicing depending on what
aspect you're focusing on this is a
totally live practice although it's a
very limited drill and in this what
we're gonna do is we're gonna do what we
call Chi she was a kite she wasn't means
turn over drill right so uh waz I means
a grouping of techniques in Chi she
needs to turn something over so the main
objective in this is to try and turn the
weapon over it's what you're trying to
do so I'm gonna call Josh am I in here
and we're gonna run through this phasing
drill for you guys all right thank you
very much okay so this drill focuses on
a night fright so we're gonna have a
knife involved in this drill basically
what's gonna be great about this
practice is if you want to see Aikido
techniques appear bunch this drill is
gonna do it for you um and I would
recommend if you're still really hung up
on doing I to their techniques and
trying to do forms and stuff then I
would recommend running this drill a lot
and it's gonna teach you basically how
those naturally appeared so that will
content your parts that I can Oh
techniques naturally do appear all the
time they totally happen and this drill
kind of forces them to happen a lot
because of the way it's built this is a
contrived drill so I'm not saying this
is totally a live drill and I think this
is akin to when you're doing Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and you're just rolling right
and this is a colloquial thing but we
used to say this you know we're just
rolling it just rolling means word me
what neither one of us are really super
trying to get each other we're just
having a good time when we're working
with the techniques and we're trying to
do stuff on each other and giving each
other opportunities so no one's going
the hardest and that's different than if
you're in a competition school where you
know every time you're trying to get as
hard as you possibly can and there's
places for both of those practices so
this is a live practice essentially but
it's a real mellow live practice so so
don't think you know this is not our on
board practice or anything like that
okay so what we're gonna do this is one
person is gonna have a weapon okay so
this is a dull training knife don't
train with a real life we're always
going to start from a graph so my Josh
can offers hand down and mines either
gonna grab the top day or yakitori now
there's a progression we usually use for
this I'm just gonna kind of show this
drill let my lion Josh go a little bit
so you can see what they do but it's
always
from this position like some kind of
single hand grab either quítate or yaku
tang after we start then they can kind
of do whatever now Josh clears himself
clearly right says let's say gets to a
defensive position to put her in the
fence just for a second okay so let's
say he gets to a position like this he's
then gonna let her grab his hand again
because this drill is to train when
someone has caught your weapon hand
that's the purpose so he's not gonna try
to keep the weapon away from her once he
gets free that's not the point of this
in wrongdoer yourself like that that's
definitely the point but not in this
drill so he gets free and he's like oh
she's gonna have a real hard time
getting me it's the distance whatever
he's gonna stop that and immediately go
back to this practice
another reason he's gonna do that is
because this is what we're training okay
now you can go as fast as hard as you
want right now these guys are gonna go
pretty mellow right so not real life but
pretty mellow and just so you can see
things and if I see any good easy clear
techniques I'll call them off if
anything awesome appears but they're not
neither one of you are trying to do
technique okay now what's gonna happen
in this is Maya's objective is to create
Chi Chi to dis on Josh and get the
weapon so she can begin to use it so if
she disarmed him in some way Hey
now the rules have switched right so now
josh she's gonna try to take the weapon
from Maya and they're gonna go back at
it now again of course if Maya distance
or put him in the fence she would then
give him the hand so that's what she's
trying to do is give him that hand okay
so we're gonna start from this position
we're going to start and this is great
hey and Josh is gonna try to get the
weapon from my if he gets it from her
then the roles just instantly switch and
they go around they're gonna be going at
a pretty moderate pace no one's going as
hard as they can here so this is just a
real moderate practice if you want to
call it a semi live or semi compliant
drill that's fine I would say this is a
live before the focus that we're having
because he's really trying to take the
weapon from her and she's really trying
to keep the weapon in her hand although
she is always going back to this
position
because that's what we're working on
okay somebody say go and I'm still let
these guys go all right go
it's a sort of guy it's another code of
guys and there's a switch and there's
another typical guy in a defense and
ASCII code of guys in an eto enemy fuel
and a song fuel and hood guy good switch
good turnover typical guys she got it
there we go you try to meet the oh
now she's you got it after all
the ste code of guys another code of
guys in code guys food which is
perfectly cool so you'll see that
techniques will appear drop seven over
the top hey good she's trying to come in
switch in the night turning over going
through job okay young man all right now
depending on the people you have in the
matchups you have if you have a short
and tall person you might see more kokyu
nage and more Shiho nage you have people
at the same height you probably can see
lots of eCos corrugations and Nico's
which is what you saw here depending on
the abilities and the physicalities of
the two different people the drill is
going to match up a little different
ways but if give it enough time and you
do this you'll see all the Aikido
techniques at one point in my life I
went through a checklist where I said
have I ever done a coda gosh like this
if I ever done she'll nage like this
right over done okay now this practice
understand this is not an ultimate
practice what this is basically teaching
you to do is in a semi-live way how to
begin to apply the techniques now when
you go full steam heart you will use
these same techniques they need to
appear less often and and that's not
that's to be expected because when
you're trying as hard as you can
you're not just gonna pull these
techniques off mostly what you're gonna
be relying on is the main strategies in
Texas Aikido to distance to suppress to
get toyou kinko to do all those things
that's the main goal of what we're gonna
do
but these techniques will appear when
you need to clear your hand or you need
to take something from someone else
you'll be doing these things this is
just a practice designed to kind of show
you've seen more of them than you would
normally see so it's kind of mellow so
that way we can practice them and then
by doing this you
build your ability to apply these
techniques up and then as you build it
through a practice like this when it's
live and order you'll more often see
them and more often be able to do them
so I'm Christopher behind this is our
basic kite she was a drill thanks for
watching
[Music]